anywho okay okay you don't want to talk
about you guys are three guys very
goodlooking I want to play a game okay
hello it's called Jizzy
potato uh [__] Mary kill I want you to
play why all right I could play it yeah
let's go with you play it well us two
play I go first
though you go you play come on go ahead
and be real honestly yeah because you
know I'll be honest with you
mhm I would be gay for a laugh well we
know
okay it's happened good I'm glad you
know I'm glad you know this information
okay so um [__] Mary kill and um Andre
it's not because I [__] up your name
earlier and also was in a voice and I
didn't really [__] your name up so I
don't I think you took that the wrong
I'll would kill you though that's fine
kill can I tell you something yeah look
huge relief over
here it's already done yeah it's already
done with you
Billy Bobby what's your name uh we're
good oh we're good yeah yeah all right
good yeah yeah you know
but I would do it in a very gentle way
because I know you know we we share the
same friends and whatnot and I think
you're a talented guy so thanks man you
would be a poison or something yeah yeah
yeah is that gentle I feel like that
tears you that rots you from the
inside really hurt yeah what was in this
potato yeah yeah got it um what's in
this potato I would have to marry you
marry me yeah okay cuz out of the three
I trust you the most wow wow okay or or
is it that you just really want to [__]
the [__] out of Adam no I don't want to
[__] it would be quick oh don't do that
that okay long time no no no but um I
would have to do quick because I know
him I've known him for so long right you
and we probably giggle through the whole
thing yeah come real fast you know I
mean but I you know I trust you the most
I think okay in terms of who's the top
yeah me Adam Adam yeah well um are we
giving are we receiving he's he's very
much a gentle bottom so I can't imagine
you doing anything else or being
anything else I what do you mean I'm a
gentle bottom you're a gentle bottom
you're like a receiver you're not an
initiator you're just a you know you lay
there you're a pillow princess you're a
pillow princess you're a dead F pillow
princess fine that's fine but
you
you killed him this episode's brought to
you by my pillow so now in this [__]
Mary kill I have to [__]
you no you get to I get yeah you get to
I'm dead yeah yeah would you rather me
[__] you uh no I think I'd prefer the
[__] probably yeah yeah how about
this I'll pretend I'm
sleeping I'll I'll do this with my hands
and I'll be on my stomach like this I'll
have my legs apart like this I don't
know if that makes it
better worse in a lot of why uh I will
be sleeping then not pretend okay still
is that better but you have I have a
letter I you have my
consent there's a letter side letter
Adam how about Adam's
sleeping I feel like I'd prefer that way
more why you why do you prefer it cuz
then I don't have to know it's happening
he's a ghost masturbating to here's what
here's what I'm on like a
barbituate okay
it's I'm not even an open pict out but
we would still have to sign a consent
form no like it's just signed it's on my
back okay is that what we signed when we
came in here yes wow cool you feel
drowsy do you feel drowsy the Noms are
[Laughter]
working in Hawaii yeah so your turn um
let me see oh boy oh boy what yeah it's
a weird thing for me to play just I've
already been killed yeah to pick him to
something else
I I how about you gilber you go go uh
let me ask some questions to help the
audience too audience play along with
this um who